"THE FIVE" ."
ISLAMIC TERRORISTS KILLED
HUNDREDS IN SRI LANKA ON
EASTER SUNDAY.
WHAT IS KEY BEYOND THE HORROR
WAS THAT THE TARGETED COUNTRY
WAS AWARE OF THE THREAT AND THIS
NUGGET FROM "USA TODAY."
"THE COUNTRY'S PRIME MINISTER
AND HIS CABINET WERE UNAWARE OF
THE INTELLIGENCE UNTIL AFTER THE
ATTACKS DUE TO POLITICAL
DYSFUNCTION."
POLITICAL DYSFUNCTION, WHICH IS
REALLY CODE FOR DEADLY
INCOMPETENCE AND TAKING YOUR EYE
OFF THE BALL.
IT IS SOMETHING TO REMEMBER, AS
OUR MEDIA INVITES US TO CHASE
PHANTOMS OF THEIR OWN MAKING,
LOSS AND FEVER DREAMS OR
OCCLUSION, OBSTRUCTION,
IMPEACHMENT, HATE HOAXES, STORMY
AND AVENATTI IS THAT REAL EVIL
STILL STALKS THIS PLANET AND
TERROR IS LIQUID, ALWAYS SEEKING
THE PATH OF LEAK LEAST
RESISTANCE.
THE PATH IS OFTEN CARVED BY HER
OWN DISTRACTION SPARKED BY THOSE
WHO THINK POLITICS IS FAR MORE
IMPORTANT THAN OUR SAFETY WHICH
IS WHY TERROR CAN COMPETE WITH
THE MUELLER REPORT EVEN ON
EASTER.
NOTHING MATTERS EXCEPT WINNING
THAT NEWS CYCLE.
IT HAPPEN FAR AWAY AND IN
AMERICA, IT'S A PEACEFUL TIME
BUT ONLY BECAUSE THERE ARE
PEOPLE YOU DON'T KNOW MAKING
SURE IT'S STILL PEACEFUL UNTIL
ONE DAY WHEN TERROR STRIKES AS
AT HOME, AS IT HAS BEFORE.
WE CAN'T FORGET THAT AMERICA IS
TERROR TARGET NUMBER ONE AND
THAT OUR NUMBER ONE PRIORITY
ISN'T IMPEACHMENT BUT SECURITY,
OUR BORDERS, GRADE, LANDMARKS,
WATER, FOOD SUPPLY.
EVERYTHING IS UP FOR GRABS IN A
TIME WHERE TERROR HAS
SMARTPHONES TOO AND WHEN
SOMETHING BIG FINALLY STRIKES
WINNING A NEWS CYCLE LOOKS WHERE
THAN PETTY IT'S DOWNRIGHT
DANGEROUS.
EMILY, WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
BEFORE.
AL QAEDA CAN COME AND GO.
I ISIS CAN DISAPPEAR BUT THERE
WILL ALWAYS BE AN IDEOLOGY AND
IT WILL ALWAYS GIVE BIRTH TO
SOMETHING NEW.
>> Emily: I AGREE.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IN THE
CONTEXT OF THEIR NEEDS TO BE
SOME DETAILED AND PLANNED LEVELS
OF THE GLOBAL MESSAGING WITH
ISLAMIC TERRORISM AND THOSE
FUNDAMENTALISTS, WE NEED TO
ADDRESS IT.
I AGREE THAT WHEN YOU HOARD
INFORMATION AND WHEN YOU HAVE
POLITICAL INFIGHTING THAT
PREVENTS YOU FROM SHARING THAT
INFORMATION, THAT COST LIVES.
WE ARE ON A DANGEROUS
TRAJECTORY, NOT TO BE A FEE OR
MONGER BUT WE ARE AS WELL.
IF THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE ARE
FOCUSED ON, IT
SECURITY FIRST.
I THINK YES, THE MESSAGING IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT'S TRAVELING
AROUND THE WORLD.
>> Greg: DANA, THEY HAD A TWO
WEEK'S ADVANCED WARNING?
DID THEY NOT TAKE IT SERIOUSLY
OR WAS IT JUST SOMETHING THAT
JUST GOT LOST?
>> Dana: THEY WILL HAVE TO
FIND OUT BUT WHAT A WAY TO
FIGURE IT OUT, AFTERWARDS.
SECRETARY POMPEO WAS QUITE
GRACIOUS TODAY TO THE SRI
LANKANS, SAY THAT WE WILL HELP
AND PROVIDE THIS BUT WE'VE BEEN
HELPING AND WE HELP ALL THESE
COUNTRIES.
MAYBE THEY DON'T GET ENOUGH
FOREIGN AID AS THEY WOULD LIKE
BUT THEY HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
FOR US TOO.
THEY HAVE TO BE WILLING TO SHARE
THE INFORMATION WITH EACH OTHER
OR AT LEAST WITH US.
I GOT THE STATISTICS TODAY FROM
THE BRAIN ROOM, SINCE 2012,
23,177 CHRISTIANS HAVE BEEN
KILLED FOR FAITH-RELATED
REASONS.
23,000.
IT IS ABHORRENT, ACCEPTABLE, AND
IF WE ARE GOING TO PROVIDE AID
AND WERE GOING TO PROVIDE
INTELLIGENCE SERVICES, SHARING,
MILITARY GEAR, WHATEVER IT IS
THEY NEED, THE LEAST THEY CAN DO
IS PASS IT UP THE CHAIN THAT
THERE WAS GOING TO BE AN
ATTACKER COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED.
>> Greg: JUAN, THERE WERE
EIGHT COORDINATED DETONATIONS.
THIS IS A GROUP WE'VE NEVER
HEARD OF BUT IT'S KIND OF THE
SAME THING, RIGHT?
IT MUTATES, CHANGES, EVOLVES,
GETS BETTER.
>> Juan: THIS IS THE ARGUMENT
THAT WE HAVE HERE BEFORE I START
THAT, LET ME SAY THE KIDS THAT
DIED, A FIFTH GRADER FROM A
SCHOOL IN D.C.
THREE OF THE FOUR CHILDREN OF A
DANISH BILLIONAIRE WHO IS THE
BIGGEST LANDOWNER IN BRITAIN.
I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE THE DEPTH
OF HIS SADNESS.
JAPANESE PEOPLE WERE KILLED.
THIS WAS A WORLDWIDE EVENT IN
THAT SENSE.
IT TOUCHED US ALL.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP
IN MIND AND WE SEE IT IN THE
U.S., MORE SECURITY IN OUR
CHURCHES IN THE AFTERMATH OF
THIS, AND THERE WERE SOME
SUSPICIONS WENT BACK TO
NOTRE DAME IN PARIS.
IT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
WHEN YOU HEAR PEOPLE SAY ISIS IS
DEFEATED, I WORRY ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE PEOPLE MIGHT THINK THEN
WE DON'T HAVE A THREAT BUT WE DO
HAVE A THREAT.
WE HAVE A THREAT, AS YOU
DESCRIBED, AS YOU SAID WATER
GOES WHEREVER THERE IS AN
OPENING.
WE SEE IS THIS IDEOLOGY SHIFTS
AND WE'VE NEVER HEARD OF THIS
GROUP.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY POP UP AND
THEY ARE BOMBING A CHURCH IN
SRI LANKA AND THEY ARE GOING
AFTER CHRISTIANS.
TO ME, IT'S A GENERATIONAL
FIGHT.
THE IDEOLOGY UNFORTUNATELY IS
NOT DEFEATED AND WE AS AMERICANS
CANNOT LOSE SIGHT OF THE FACT
THAT WE ARE IN AN ONGOING FIGHT.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT BOASTS FOR
WHATEVER REASON THAT ISIS IS
DEFEATED, DON'T BE FOOLED.
WE'VE GOT TO KEEP UP NOT ONLY
THE ATTENTION BUT THE FIGHT.
WITH REGARD TO THE INTELLIGENCE,
WE KNOW THERE'S SOME ARGUMENTS
ABOUT, DID WE KNOW WHAT WAS
COMING ON 9/11.
YOU CAN BLAME AND SAY THEY ARE
INCOMPETENT, THEY ARE NOT THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT, NOT U.S.
INTELLIGENCE, NOT ISRAELI
INTELLIGENCE.
THE FACT IS THE PEOPLE
RESPONSIBLE ARE THE TERRORISTS.
>> Dana: CAN I CLARIFY?
AFTER 9/11 IS WHEN WE TOOK DOWN
THE WALL BETWEEN INTELLIGENCE
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
THEN WE STEPPED UP EFFORTS ALL
AROUND THE WORLD TO MAKE SURE
THOSE GOVERNMENTS WHERE YOU KNEW
THAT THERE WERE HOT SPOTS WOULD
HAVE WHAT THEY NEEDED IN ORDER
TO SHARE THE INFORMATION AND
HAVE THE EQUIPMENT.
WE LEARNED A LESSON.
IF ARE GOING TO HELP THESE
COUNTRIES, THE LEAST THEY CAN
DO, THEY HAVE THE INFORMATION.
THEY DIDN'T PASS IT ON.
>> Juan: CORRECT.
I THINK WE'VE MADE CHANGES AND
WE HAVE ADAPTED POST-9/11 BUT I
JUST DON'T LIKE THE IDEA THAT WE
WOULD SAY IT'S THEIR FAILURE.
PEOPLE DID THAT TO US.
I DIDN'T LIKE IT.
I DIDN'T THINK WAS FAIR TO US OR
OUR GOVERNMENT.
I THINK THE TERRORISTS ARE THE
ONES WHO SHOULD BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE.
>> Greg: JESSE, WE'VE SEEN
DIFFERENT RESPONSES, SOME ARE
ODD.
WOULD YOU CARE TO PICK THE ONES
THAT DISCUSSED YOU THE MOST?
>> Jesse: I HAVE
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HERE AND
IT'S JUST KIND OF DISGUSTING.
CHRISTIANITY UNDER ATTACK.
SRI LANKA CHURCH BOMBINGS STOKE
FAR RIGHT ANGER IN THE WEST.
IT'S A WHOLE ARTICLE, NOT ABOUT
EDITORIALIZING ABOUT RADICAL
ISLAM, MURDERING PEOPLE.
IT'S EDITORIALIZING AND SAYING
OH, CHRISTIANS ARE UPSET THAT
CHURCHES ARE BEING BOMBED.
THEY ARE MAKING CHRISTIANS AND
CONSERVATIVES OUT TO BE THE
VILLAINS FOR REACTING TO
TERRORIST ATTACKS.
LOOK AT SOME OF THE LEADING
DEMOCRATS, HOW THEY CHARACTERIZE
IT.
THEY DIDN'T USE CHRISTIANS.
THEY DIDN'T SAY CHURCHES.
HE ACTUALLY SAID EASTER
WORSHIPERS WERE UNDER ATTACK.
YOU DON'T CALL MUSLIMS
RAMADAN-WORSHIPERS.
YOU DON'T CALL JEWS
PASSOVER-WORSHIPERS.
IT'S A MADE-UP PHRASE.
WHY DID THEY MAKE UP PHRASES
LIKE THIS?
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS PEOPLE
DON'T TRUST LIBERALS BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT IN TOUCH WITH
REALITY.
THEY DO THIS BECAUSE THEY ARE
PANDERING TO MUSLIMS BECAUSE A
LOT OF LIBERALS FEEL THEY ARE SO
UPSET WITH HOW OTHER PEOPLE
THINK ABOUT THEM AND IF THEY ARE
THOUGHT UP TO BE INSENSITIVE, IT
DRIVES HIM CRAZY.
SECOND OF ALL, THEY THINK THEIR
OWN RHETORIC CAUSES ISLAMIC
EXTREMISM.
REMEMBER, BLAME AMERICA FIRST?
THEY THINK ISLAMAPHOBIA CAUSES
RADICAL ISLAM SO THEY DO
WHATEVER THEY CAN TO SANITIZE
IT.
BUZZFEED ACTUALLY CAME OUT, ONE
OF THEIR EDITORS, AND SAID
PRESIDENT TRUMP, IMAGINE HOW
OUTRAGED HE WOULD BE IF WHITES
WERE THE VICTIMS OF THE
SRI LANKA ATTACK.
I FOUND THAT COMPLETELY
DESPICABLE TO PLAY THE RACE CARD
AFTER A TERRORIST ATTACK.
IT'S WHAT THEY DID IN CATENA.
REMEMBER, BUSH?
HE WOULD'VE ACTED FASTER IF THEY
WERE WHITE VICTIMS IN LOUISIANA.
WHEN I STEP BACK AND THINK ABOUT
IT, CONSERVATIVES ARE PRETTY
COLOR-BLIND WHEN IT COMES TO
LIFE.
THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT RACES, BABIES AND THE
WARMS.
THEY WANT TO PROTECT ALL LIFE.
HAVE A LOT OF CONSERVATIVES IN
THE MEDIA WHO TALK ABOUT
STOPPING THE CARNAGE IN THE
SOUTH SIDE OF CHICAGO.
I THINK IT'S REALLY UNFAIR WHEN
THE MEDIA ALWAYS, NO MATTER WHO
DOES THAT, IF IT'S A WHITE
PERPETRATOR, MUSLIM PERPETRATOR,
HISPANIC PERPETRATOR, THEY JUST